now the reason free speech is so
important is because liberals and
conservatives have to communicate in
order to keep society going and it's
communication that's central to free
speech you have to be able to talk to
each other well that's what worries me
too in the era of of Trump and I'm
thrilled to see leftists losing their
minds I'd lie if I said that weren't the
case but you know because you're a bad
person it is because of course that's
why so that that is it really I'm not
going to lie I was worried that that
would I was worried that the self
autherine would be boring and it was
fascinating do you ever worry though
because it seems like something would be
so helpful for a lot of people now with
the recent controversy that some some
people who might otherwise be open to
the idea just shutting it down or not
wanting to be involved with it because
they don't like what you have to say no
it's exactly the opposite it's become
what's the public support for me is
probably running at 25 to 1 sure yeah so
what shall I caddy me a'right people who
might implement this into their
curriculum I don't know maybe that's not
your they have it anyways right so your
goal is to go directly to the consumer
is it oh absolutely yeah yeah yeah we've
I mean we are talking with a variety of
different businesses and some businesses
are using it but sure but know this is
direct and some educational institutions
but no it's direct to individual that's
the right wait that seems to be the
right way to do it yeah does well I
would imagine that uh shows like Rogan
and into its own degree this show
hopefully help with that because having
your own reach now is certainly
attainable yes people need to understand
that this you know the Knights of 50
million viewers you know on three
networks are gone yeah something
certainly are you really well
individually you know we can have a plot
of land that we're pretty pretty happy
about I refer to it kind of as the
digital version of the Agricultural
Revolution as opposed to the Industrial
Revolution we have a few people you know
who ran the networks and everyone worked
for them now many people can work for
themselves yeah it's amazing yeah it's a
smaller plot of land but it can be very
effective especially with what it's not
that small either I mean your reach is
not trivial well I have it's not it's
always of course it's it's less
respected because of the likes of not
gay Jared on this program yeah well I
think it's it's a testament to your
character that you still employ them I
know well that's the whole thing so
character does matter and so you are I'm
not mischaracterizing you by saying
about a Christian well that's a
complicated question but
we'll go with yes okay well first let's
go why is that a complicated question
well because I've been studying
religious belief for a very long time
and one of the problems with I would say
with modern Christianity this is a
terrible over generalization is that the
Christians haven't done a very good job
of separating their claims from
scientific claims right and that's
particularly true on the fundamentalist
Protestant side of the distribution and
then and the reason there is that it's
not obvious to people that there are
more that there can be more than one
type of truth and what my my
understanding is that religious truth is
fundamentally behavioral truth its truth
to act out and that that doesn't make it
less true in fact in some sense it makes
it more true mm-hmm
this is a philosophical issue that we
can't discuss because it's too
time-consuming but roughly speaking
there's two things that people need to
know they need to know what the world is
made of and they need to know how to act
in it and proper religious doctrines are
about how to act in the world they're
about the world as a place of action and
the world is a place of action and
religious stories lay out the structure
of the world as a place of action yeah
and then they tell you how to act in it
and and their reasons for that and so
well you know I find that interesting
because I was talking about this with
gosh I don't know who I was talking with
us about but this idea you know the
Christian idea of sort of
complementarianism that male male and
females have different biological
contributions to make that they have
different brains they're developed
differently they have different driving
factors is something that's sort of
being caught up too with a lot of this
anti social justice leftism anti
feminism that I don't think was really
discussed for a long time I think you
see a lot of women who've rejected this
blurring of gender lines going you know
what yeah I think I think we realize now
that as you said there's there's an
academic gap for men well if you look at
the way we tailor education it's not
tailored to males and that's because
males tend to learn in a different
environment public education certainly
United States is entirely tailored to
the female brain to the way they learn
environment sitting very very vocal very
communicative it's interesting that
there are some like ISA behavioral
throw-up shoots or how to act in it that
people can find well it's so or so with
regards to belief you know what
it's to me you determine what someone
believes not by listening to what they
say they believe because that's actually
their representation of what they
believe and that might be true and it
might not be because lots of people
don't act out what they say right
and so when you assess someone at the
deepest possible level you look at what
they do and that's the best indicator of
what they believe now that's a different
way of looking at belief because we tend
to think about belief as a as something
that's associated with a set of facts
you know that's a scientific viewpoint
now religious systems like Judaism and
Christianity were established far before
human beings had a scientific viewpoint
they weren't scientific to begin with
and they're not scientific now science
wasn't really invented all things
considered until 500 years ago right and
so the now it's not that easy to
understand that there can be different
forms of truth for different purposes
and I'm not making a moral relativism
claim it's a very difficult thing to get
straight but a lot of the apparent
tension between religious belief and
scientific belief falls away when you
start to understand that moral moral
doctrines which is what religious
systems are are about how you interact
with one another how you conduct
yourself and the guidelines in
Christianity for example are very
sophisticated they're very sophisticated
I'm speaking about that as as someone
who knows a fair bit about psychological
theories in general and them even the
more profound clinical theories like
Rogers theory of personal development is
very very heavily influenced by
Christianity oh they're all very heavily
influenced by Christianity and there's
the central doctrine of Christianity
roughly speaking is that to put it very
briefly is that life is difficult and
there's a lot of suffering and pain in
it and that can warp and corrupt you and
it can make you murderous it can make it
genocide all this because the suffering
can become unbearable and turn you
against life itself could make you a
Scientologist
well even that's I wasn't even going to
go there I know I was yeah but I crossed
the line so yes you did you did you did
you crossed the line
and the essential idea in Christianity
in my opinion is that the best antidote
to
his truth is to speak the truth and to
live your life that way and to act in
the manner that you speak and that
that's your fundamental moral obligation
and I do believe that that idea is the
cornerstone of Western civilization well
it's being the Western civilization to
kind of wrap this all up in about what
do you think is going to happen you you
obviously you're Pro free speech you're
anti safe space trigger warning and it's
all sort of stemming from the gender
pronoun issue for you in a nutshell you
said that's what brought all the
attention yeah that's all the attention
obviously I have much more to say we'd
love to have you back to say more well
but since that is such a hot-button
issue right now we've talked about that
my producer not gay Jared and Jordan
who's in here and they've gone so far so
quickly I was like when we have same-sex
marriage what do we do I don't know
where do [ __ ] take a dump and let's
make that the next civil rights movement
do you think there's going to be being a
sort of understanding I guess
consumerist behavior or sociology do you
think there's going to be a rejection of
it and people are just going to it's
going to go too far and it will likely
go back to simplest I think the simplest
outcome is increasing polarization and
misunderstanding that's the most likely
outcome because he the stupidest easiest
outcome is the one that's most likely
right because you don't have to do
anything and you can be clueless and
it'll get a nihilist yeah it doesn't
mean it's the inevitable your Christian
Norman
Christopher Nolan naki doodle get me if
I don't get that right as well so
hopefully there's an alternative and I
think the alternative I believe and I
believe this for a very long time is
that the alternative is for people to
learn about their civilization to
incorporate its proper doctrines into
their behavior and to grow up and live
properly and carefully awake and to
speak carefully to act carefully and
that I believe that if enough people do
that then we'll avoid the polarization
that's that's the inevitable consequence
because the problem is is that people
who are character illogically weak and I
don't mean this in a judgemental sense I
mean weak and that they can't withstand
the onslaught of life and they get hurt
because of it they turn to nihilism
where they turn to ideology and and when
they do those things polarize even if
they turn to ideology it's it's a
toss-up whether it's the radical right
or the radical left it depends on their
character you know and then
that and that requires very little
effort on people's part you can learn
the rules to those games very rapidly
and then people polarize and then they
have someone to hate and they don't have
to take any responsibility and you know
what's what's sort of funny about that
statement is I have no problem with
people having an ideological bias have
no problem people seeing the world
through a prism I think we all do my
thing is if your left or your right just
don't lie to me but ironically enough we
were probably one of the most balanced
shows on the primaries and on Trump and
I can't stand Hillary Clinton I couldn't
stand the left but I certainly would
criticize Trump where I thought it was I
would infuriate people but I have no
problem saying I am a conservative I
look to the world through that lens um
one of the things me to be somewhat
objective because I'm aware of yes well
that's about the best you could do I
mean one of the things that our research
and other people's research has
indicated that is that conservatives are
conservative and liberals liberal
because of their temperaments it's
partly biological mmm so for example
conservatives tend to be higher in
conscientiousness which is
industriousness and orderliness
particularly orderliness and lower in
openness sound like someone so and and
crucified him for not putting things
away prior ha ha well and the
orderliness seems to be the thing that's
that's driving things on the
conscientiousness side and so what that
means is that conservatives roughly
speaking make better managers and
administrators
okay now liberals are higher in openness
which is both interest in ideas and
interest in aesthetics and they're lower
in conscientiousness and so and one of
the consequences of that is that they
tend to make better entrepreneurs and
artists and so our society is basically
set up and this is something people
really need to think about is that but
that's odd because nearly all business
owners tend to be more conservative not
the entrepreneurs go to Silicon Valley
well come on you're talking about a
limited amount of people and Steve Jobs
beats the [ __ ] out of his kids well we
look I I work I I do consulting work for
this company called the founder
Institute and we've tested 40,000
would-be entrepreneurs from all over the
world 165 different cities it's the
biggest early-stage tech incubator in
the world now the guy who runs it a day
or se has created 2,500 new businesses
in four years doing this and we know
what predicts entrepreneurial
and the the so the Liberals are really
interested in how ideas relate to one
another and they like to jump from one
thing to another and it does make them
more creative but they're not very good
at implementation whereas the
Conservatives are very good at
implementation and a detail and so
roughly speaking the Conservatives need
the Liberals to start companies and to
generate new ideas even though a lot of
those ideas are going to be bad right
okay but the Liberals need the
Conservatives to run the damn companies
now you can be temperamental e
conservative and temperamental e liberal
and and those are valid viewpoints
because there's a place for those
viewpoints in the world they can
function as tools but what you have to
do is exactly what you just said if your
conservative you need to listen to the
Liberals because they have some things
to tell you and the Liberals and I think
they're far worse at this at the moment
by the way the Liberals have to learn
that can listen to the Conservatives
because the Conservatives hold things
together and stabilize things right yeah
well so the dialogue now the reason free
speech is so important is because
liberals and conservatives have to
communicate in order to keep society
going and though and it's communication
that's central to free speech you have
to be able to talk to each other or you
separate into armed camps and you either
one becomes the other slave one becomes
a tyrant right or there's conflict why
that's what worries me too in the era of
of Trump and I'm thrilled to see
leftists losing their minds I'd lie if I
said that weren't the case but you know
because you're a bad person it is
because I'm a worse that's black and you
know we always with the election night
came around we kind of voted say
Republican ticket and Helder knows I
think I think everyone at louder was
quite or did with a few exceptions but
it is I still want to be able to
criticize him without people going
absolutely ballistic and I see that for
the first time being bred on the right
so to speak I don't think these people
are conservative but on the left it was
well known that they couldn't handle
criticism you had to follow lockstep it
was a very narrow tent the Republican
Party was a very wide tent and now in
the air of Trump people get so personal
and vindictive if you just say you know
what I don't support a 35% tariff on
companies having to outsource jobs to
remain remain afloat and they get
furious so I don't know if you noticed
that in in Canada but certainly in the
States for the first time that sort of
dogmatic anti critical
speak of their preferred leader you know
that be part of the polarization process
right I think media is largely
responsible we talked about this and
then also New York Times never when were
talking about this let me present to you
two worlds as the the layman that I am
mom joins Facebook she's pro-trump
daughter drone joins Facebook YouTube
she's pro-hillary right Oh Donald
Trump's going to be a great president
like Donald Trump has billion cabinet
appointments like the daughter Donald
Trump doesn't release his tax returns
like Donald Trump is a rapist like so
you go six months and you've liked these
pages and you've consumed information
that way well the Facebook algorithm a
YouTube algorithm it's not hey you might
really need to hear it's you might also
like to the point where people entirely
consume information that is nothing but
confirmation pipes and and I would even
see what happens then is that amplifies
their temperamental proclivities right
and we have research showing this too so
conservatives do tend to to consume
media that that fosters a conservative
viewpoint and so the Liberals and so one
of the ways I mean this was the whole
purpose of Education at one point is
that yes as to suppose you was expose
you to views that contradicted your own
and to help you find value in those
alternative views yeah and so and the
reason for that was to help you get out
of your confirmation bias and the
tendency of that to auger you into a
narrow view point that is no longer
representative of the world right it's
really a bad thing when that happens
it's like it's like you're a celebrity
that's completely surrounded by
sycophants who only tell you what you
want to hear exactly what happens is
that because you're not getting any
corrective information anymore your
weaknesses don't get corrected and they
start to take you over right now and
that's I that's exactly what's happening
in our polarized political landscape
it's like the weaknesses of the radical
left viewpoint are starting to
predominate to dominate the entire
spectrum on the left side of the yeah I
think well I think it's already
dominated the left for a long time and
now unfortunately I see it permeating
the right a little bit where they are
willing to cannibalize themselves just
because you're critical of one action of
Trump and that really worries me in the
United States yeah well the thing about
criticism is for a political leaders
that criticism can be a really good
thing because if you're a good critic
you don't only say why the person is
wrong you offer some alternatives that
might be better and we force them to
sharpen their arguments and credit
people think of criticism as
insult something like that and that
criticism is here's a way that you could
have done that better right and that you
want that you want criticism from other
people I mean it's hard to do and I
think I do and what's what's sort of
ironic in all this is that we view we
used to say to fringe sort of your left
my right the fringe left their left so
don't let it's okay I know you're I know
you're very educated man I'm doing it
for them your left my right and then the
fringe my left your right but really
that's mainstream left and right now
they aren't fringe and it seems like in
the middle is what would once have been
called the fringe I don't consider
myself a moderate but I find much more
common ground with you than I do many
Republicans certainly nearly all
liberals and just being a critical
thinker that seems like we're a
shrinking minority to the point where we
would really be considered more fringe
than someone with a Trump sign in a
funny hat or a social justice warrior
who has a snowflake t-shirt and is
crying in the corner well that's a
consequence of polarization yeah because
when things polarized then viewpoints
become increasingly black and white and
they become increasingly simple and the
problem with that like I think it was
Einstein who said that an explanation
should be as simple as possible but no
simpler and political beliefs should be
like that too they should be simple as
possible but no simpler and the thing
about political beliefs is they're not
beliefs about statements of fact about
the world they're beliefs about how to
move forward resolve problems and the
the real test of a political belief is
can it specify a problem and then can it
solve the problem and the way that we
practice those political beliefs and
their formulation is through is through
dialogue and critical dialogue and the
critical dialogue is while here we've
got a bad representation of this you
have a bad representation of a poor
representation and so do I so let's keep
that's what we're doing right now let's
keep talking about it until our model of
the problem is more and more and more
detailed and then maybe we can start to
generate some solutions and then maybe
we can start to agree on those solutions
and implement them and test them well I
don't know exactly of what problem it is
but your Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
is certainly a model of some deeply
rooted problem in Canada and I hope you
guys fix it
Jordan Peterson Jordan Peterson videos
at Jordan B Peterson on Twitter and the
future authoring program what's that
it's at self authoring calm self
authoring calm yeah I thought I had that
right I did not mr. Peterson please come
back with us thanks for the interview
you didn't say yes to them you're not
coming back yes it remains to be seen
this always happens a lot with Crowder
stay tuned or don't he won't
I'd be happy to come back subscribe
below dude dude if you don't I'll raid
your house just click Subscribe that's
about as good as I get musically it's
not a music channel I don't know what to
tell you if you don't subscribe I will
find you and I'll sing to you personally